one of the reasons I ask clay shirky to
come to this series and he can only do a
Monday night and that's why we're here
is the long now foundation since we
started almost ten years ago have been
worrying about everything going digital
and then everything digital going
temporary and in terms of continuity of
civilization that is not a formula for
success and probably many here have
already found that accounting files or
Word files or things from a decade ago I
may still be on floppy disks that
actually floppy but you can't recover it
with anything the hardware has moved on
the software has moved on and it's as if
you never wrote whatever it was like
kind of thing that's happening on a
massive scale um and it's not going to
get better it so far it's just going to
get worse I've seen clay shirky working
on this subject a little bit with
Library of Congress which is starting to
step up to the issue Congress even put a
couple hundred million dollars toward
trying to take on digital preservation
and the point to realize is that digital
storage is easy we do it all the time
but digital preservation is keeping
things fit for use over decades and
centuries please in millennia would be
nice what we're doing it long now is
kurt volker who is here is cranking up a
website which is similar to our rosetta
project which is collecting all of the
spoken languages of the world online in
one place for up to several thousand now
and this will be a place where all the
file format conversion algorithms and
formulas and whatnot will be collected
so when you realize that your important
records are in some kind of file it was
a proprietary to a company which is just
in the process of going out of business
and it will become an orphan you will
find Natalie conversion formula and
algorithms but advice and what to
convert that about to be dead material
into that may last longer so this is
something long now is taking on sir
seriously for quite a while and clay is
unlike many looked at it much more in
social and cultural terms and he's the
expert in that so that's why he's
talking tonight clay shirky while he's
finding his way all the way up here to
the stage I'll say one more thing which
is you have these cards which spell out
some about clay and also have on the
back if you haven't seen it before the
format we use for questions which is
I'll bring the talk and during Q&A
afterwards go ahead and write down a
question you might have passed it to a
person in one of the yellow volunteer
hats they'll be passed up to me and
Kevin Kelly in the front and we'll pick
out the really good stuff and ask it of
clay it's helpful if you put your name
on it because then we can find you in
the audience and clay will know who he's
talking to and if you don't get e-mail
announcements of these series you put
your email address in the bottom sorry
clay it's all yours that's quite all
right thanks very much yeah let me offer
a little bit of background about where
this stewart mentioned the sort of
concern for digital preservation as a
social issue and i'll talk a little bit
about where that came from i was the the
head of the Technical Working Group that
was drafting oh sorry is that better
alright very good I was ahead of the
Technical Working Group that was
drafting the the legislative proposal
before Congress for n dip the National
digital information infrastructure and
preservation program world's worst
acronym and then in the first year of
that that programs life was responsible
for coming up some architectural
principles for federating digital
preservation during that period we
designed something called the archive
ingest and handling test where we took a
moderately complicated real-world
archive it was George Mason University's
archive of material collected after the
911 attacks and gave it to several
different institutions to see how they
would handle it differently it was as
far as we know the largest comparative
test of digital archives yet undertaken
and one of the things that struck me
during both the the end up process and
particularly
the archive in just handling test was
that all of the ways we had of handling
metadata of describing the digital
contents we were handling that had been
brought over from the offline world from
the world of handling books and
manuscripts and so forth felt like a bad
fit and so I've spent some time trying
to figure out why that is and and that's
what I want to talk about today I want
to talk about this in sort of three
three pieces first of all I want to talk
about preservation in general and
digital preservation in particular why
it's a hard problem then I want to talk
especially about classification systems
and finally I want to talk about a new
approach to creating some of the same
value we get from classification systems
without some of the rigidity which is
called tagging so I'll start by talking
about preservation the disorienting
thing and talking about preservation is
the preservation is an outcome you
cannot ever say I will preserve
something to end date because you don't
actually know like anyone who's ever
hosted anything in a who's ever was ever
had a website hosted somewhere has seen
all of the redundant backups and yet
occasionally things happen and so really
all you're doing is lowering risk right
you can't actually say I'm going to
ensure that this is preserved over a
long time all you can say is I'm going
to take as many steps as I can to
improve the chances of this being
preserved so give you an example I wrote
a book in in the early 90s called voices
from the net it was about a text-based
virtual culture muds mousse the well
echo these kinds of things I had the
misfortune to publish it or to have it
be published in april of nineteen
ninety-five which is the year that the
web was washing everything about the
text only internet away and so it was
quickly remaindered and I don't have an
electronic copy of this manuscript
although it was entirely created
electronically I shipped it off to
ziff-davis electronically and they had
not yet gotten their process completely
electronic so they also don't have an
electronic copy of this manuscript and
so although I have some incentives to
keep this work of writing around I have
failed to do it meanwhile every single
word I said on usenet in that same year
to my horror
he's perfectly preserved for all the
world to see right so this is this is
what I mean about preservation as an
outcome I would not have successfully
predicted in 93 when I was having flame
wars on using and also trying to create
a serious work that it was the flame
wars and not the serious work that would
last until now so the first order
problem we face right is that bits are
fairly temporary as i as i have heard
Stewart's a digital data last forever or
five years whichever comes first right
and there is this problem we have with
digital media where you can see here i
think the the time frames that these
things were imagined to last in
particular optical disc cds of various
sorts where we were told we're going to
last ten to a hundred years a number of
tests have shown that after a single
year many of them can exhibit
significant dropouts and everything up
here with an asterisk is a projected
number because all we know is that the
manufacturers say that's about how long
we think it's going to last it's been
tested but we haven't actually had
enough elapsed time since the invention
of those materials to know whether or
not this is going to work so you can see
here that the maximum and untested
number here is a hundred years all right
so first the first order problem we have
is if we want to keep anything around
longer than a century we have to do
something to it in the middle to
continue to preserve it and this is a
classic shearing layers problem shearing
layers of Stuart's concept from how
buildings learn and in how buildings
learn he says the interior decoration of
a room changes faster than the walls the
walls change faster than the structure
the structure changes faster than the
site and so forth so here we have the
shearing layer problem which is if we
want to keep the bits around for a long
time we have to periodically refresh the
media and so we have a zone of fast
change in a zone of slow change only the
problem is we're not actually preserving
bits one of the problems with digital
preservation is it makes it sound like
it's about keeping the digits around
when you get them back you know what it
is it's just a bunch of ones and
what you really care about is preserving
the assets right and once you care about
preserving the essence right the the use
of the material right I got these ones
and zeros out that were preserved 100
years ago and it's something called a
wang database what is that right well
it's the same as raw disk space because
you have no way of reading it back if
all you've preserved is the ones and
zeros so suddenly we realize that the
the media alone is not the only shearing
layer involved here we also have to
worry about the format right we have to
make sure that we can read it but of
course a format alone isn't enough
because it needs something to play it
back right so here we have the problem
of how do we play the format back now
the the simplest way to think of this is
I've got a Microsoft Word filed so I
need a copy of Microsoft Word to play it
back it seems I've got a format you need
a piece of software but in many cases
it's not a single piece of software
right it's actually a whole complicated
set of dependencies this is something
designed to run in flash in a particular
browser this is a Perl program which
requires these particular libraries and
so on so there's this entire complex of
shearing layers right that has to do
with the software environment that
interprets the format and of course
software doesn't run in a vacuum sorry
right then you have to start dealing
with the operating system and the
architecture and we have a fairly
standard way of thinking about operating
systems running on chips but there are
companies like transmitted that are
trying to radically alter that so you
don't just save the operating system and
the chip you then also have to save all
of the instructions that said how that
ship interpreted that particular
operating system itself and you can see
what's happening here the longer you
want to keep something the more shearing
layers there are the longer you want to
keep something the less the problem
becomes purely technological and the
more it becomes social let's do a little
thought experiment let's assume that the
Constitution was being written not in
the 1780s but in the 1980s and being the
revolution errs they were the founding
fathers would doubtless have used an
apple too
so this is now the site of the US
Constitution and since James Madison was
a bit of a cut-up we can assume that
they did the first draft and ran from
them right because why not right it's
just a draft now let's say that you
wanted to preserve this obviously a
pretty important document let's say you
wanted to preserve this with as few
shearing layers as possible I know what
to do we're going to adopt the model
from the analog world they just keep the
physical book around right and it
doesn't decay and the physical book can
last for centuries so we're not just
going to preserve the bits in appleton
appleworks format with the apple to
operating system we're actually going to
put the machine into a bath of pH
neutral non-oxidizing oil and every few
decades we're going to take it out and
dry it off and fire it up just to make
sure it works again so now imagine a
couple hundred years from now it's the
time to do this and they take the
machine out and they dry it off and
somebody says hey what's this oh that's
a power cord yeah they didn't have nano
green echo nuclear power the way they
had now they had copper wires back that
right and you think you saw the shearing
line problem until you realize you have
to emulate 120 volt 60 Hertz AC right so
there's no defense against this however
deep you want to go right it's going to
turn into a social problem at some point
because digital data sits in an
interpretive context that can't be
gotten rid of by anything other than
printing it out on paper and if you have
a kind of digital object that can't be
printed out on paper all right then
you're really stuck managing the social
issues we don't know how bad a problem
this is we can guess that it's pretty
bad and Stuart Stuart alluded to that
we've had only if we've only had digital
data around for a fairly short period so
we don't know where and when these
problems are going to appear but we have
had some early signals in 1086 during
the time William the Conqueror the Duke
the domesday book was created which is
essentially a sense
of English land and at the 900th
anniversary of the domesday book the
British Broadcasting Corporation which
was getting into the business of making
and selling the BBC micro decided that
they would do a nine hundredth
anniversary version of the domesday book
highly annotated a lot of scholarly
notes and they stored it on video discs
and in 1990 they laid everybody in that
unit off because the BBC micro had
turned out not to work that well and by
the middle of the nineties you could no
longer read the domesday book as it
appeared on the BBC micro but the
regular domesday book was just chugging
along fine all right this thing has
lasted the better part of a thousand
years this didn't make it ten two orders
of magnitude difference it was only a
couple of years ago recovered through
heroic efforts right enormous amount of
cost was was spent to try and get the
domesday book off of the BBC micro so
when you have these kind of systems what
you really have what you have to have to
make digital preservation work in this
environment is the continually refreshed
possibility for action and you can do
things to slow down the rate of
refreshment alright you can slow down
the cycles of the shearing line better
to store things on long-term storage
instead of short-term better to use
formats that are going to be more likely
long live than short-lived and so forth
but you can't stop it and so you have to
have a system where you continually
refresh the possibility for action and
seeing these two things side by side you
can see what happened to the BBC micro
which is essentially the social context
in which this continued to function
simply went away so now we can we can
elevate this to the level of a kind of
principal when thinking about mitigating
preservation risk which is that cheap
flexible systems with large numbers of
participants tend to the lower the risk
cheap flexible systems with large
numbers of participants tend to ensure
that more things will get preserved
because preservation decisions are made
on the margin right at each point that I
moved off of one
top and on to another or changed ISPs I
could have taken steps to preserve the
manuscript of that book I wrote in 1993
and at one of those steps I don't even
know which one I just didn't do it and
that's all it takes so the issue here is
not can we preserve a certain piece of
content yes you can at some expense but
if you're spending the money there what
else are you losing elsewhere there's no
way we can keep everything and so we end
up moving towards cheap and flexible
systems as a way of maximizing
maximizing the potential for
preservation and lowering the risk we
can also talk about the corollary which
is that high cost brittle systems which
are practiced by a small number of
participants on behalf of a large number
of people as with the careful encoding
of this into video discs actually tend
to increase the risk that things will be
lost over the long haul which brings me
to the subject of classification
classification have is at base about
finding things there are other second
ordered values but really it exists to
help people find things but
classification is not the only there
there are other ways to find things
besides classification systems so
consider your kitchen I hope your
kitchen doesn't look like this but
consider your kitchen right depending on
what kind of cook you are and what kind
of shopper you are there's someplace
between a thousand and ten thousand
things in your kitchen every spoon every
plate every can of beans every chopstick
right and most of those things aren't
labeled and yet you can find them pretty
well right you may be a little Messier
or a little neater but you could
probably get the work done you need to
get done in your kitchen right but you
don't have a label on the spoon that
says spoon and you don't have a label on
the drawer of spoons that says drawer of
spoons all right what's labeled in your
kitchen your cans are labeled your
spices are labeled why are those things
later they're labeled because you can't
see in them there are a lot of them
they're basically the same and they're
hard to inspect right a can of chickpeas
and a can of tomatoes weigh about the
same and without their labels they look
about the same you can't oh
open them up to figure out what's inside
them they're hard to look into right so
in those situations even when you have a
small number of things involved right
you need to fall back on labels who has
that problem in extremity libraries do
and this is the Seattle libraries the
very model of a modern major public work
right libraries have such a big problem
with multiples of objects that are about
the same and are hard to inspect that
they not only have to have lots of
labels they have to have labeled labels
and they have to label their label
labels and so on right until it rolls up
into a categorization system and the
goal the goal of classifying is
essentially to have a completely
specified domain in the case of the
library it's all of human effort so that
when new material comes along it has a
niche already provided for it in that
classification system here for example
is the Dewey Decimal System classic
example of this the idea behind doing
from the name is there are ten top level
categories which cover all of human
endeavor right within those categories
categories can be ten subcategories and
within each of those 10 sub categories
can be 10 sub sub categories and so on
and at some point you can uniquely
specify each work the advantage of this
kind of system is that a human thought
has gone into organizing it beforehand
so that as new books come in you don't
have to continually react there are
however some issues with systems like
this here for example is the Dewey
Decimal categorizations for religion
how much is this not how much is this
not what you want right the disadvantage
of systems like that is also that human
thought has gone into them the
advantages and the disadvantages of the
same thing which is to say it
necessarily reflects the bias of its
creators now it's easy to say do we
write that was obviously you know that
there's obvious bias there there wasn't
careful thought we didn't know as much
about classification systems we're
effectively over that now the Seattle
library the REM koolhaas library which
has gotten so much attention has as its
internal plan speaking of shearing lines
the idea of a continuous collection
there's a single ramp that runs through
the entire building in a flat spiral
from the top all the way to the bottom
and that ramp is poured so that the
Dewey Decimal System will be reflected
directly in the architecture of the
building it's one thing to say well the
Dewey system is a kind of a mistake and
we know that mistake we don't make those
kinds of mistakes anymore all right
except that we do in fact we are
currently pouring our mistakes into
concrete right it's going to be a long
time before mistakes like this leave the
system because they're actually being
made more and more durable rather than
less and less right do we of course is
not the only classification system there
are more sophisticated ones for example
the Library of Congress classification
scheme obviously by going with letters
and having multiples of letters right
you have a much more flexible namespace
much more possibility of subdivision and
it wasn't the product of a single mind
there's actually a group that's
responsible for for creating and
maintaining this but even here right we
want to run into issues so here is d
right general and old world history
first of all history about the new world
in history about the old world or
different kinds of history are in
different categories within this system
but here we are in D general old world
history and I'd like to call your
attention to the three items that are
colored the Balkan Peninsula Asia
africa and just you know to review the
geography okay I was good just going to
do this example with Switzerland which
also gets its own top-level category two
dozen you show up on this math right so
what's being optimized here am I am i
off I like to switch you all right
group together what they've said is we
can't eat the reshelving costs of
exploding the top level system so we
have to leave decay covering the things
DK has always covered we're just going
to add former to the front end of that
well it's only 15 years ago right except
to a 22 year old right for whom the
Soviet Union collapsed when they were
still running around the playground it's
hard to remember which countries go in
that category right and play that out
all right how long does this get stay
wrong before they fix it what if you had
to remember which American states were
former British colonies before you could
look them up what if you had to remember
which southern European countries were
former Moorish colonies before you had
to pick them up right former Hittite
Empire yes or no right at some point
right and this is where long now ish
thinking comes in at some point right
this goes from being a minor annoyance
to being a real impediment to using the
system and yet another example like
gypsies right I love this all right the
idea is essentially history is primarily
geographically arranged right geography
is destiny is an idea embedded in this
classification system overall and yet
here we have gypsies who plainly defeat
country right defeat the idea of country
if you're going to be talking about a
history and yet if gypsies are there
where the Kurds where is the Jewish
Diaspora right this is the deeper you
look the more these kinds of systems
reveal themselves to be ways of managing
the physical contents the analog problem
of the book world and less about actual
world view now it's easy to say right
okay this is about books right we now
have all of this digital data right
these are classes of mistakes that we
accept because it's better than the
alternative which is chaos right books
aren't inspected they have to have
labels and there are so many labels that
the labels have to have labels so this
is the kind of system we need for books
and we just take the fact that it's not
as good as we'd like but we don't surely
need to make those mistakes in the
digital world so a little over 10 years
ago two guys out of Stanford decided
that we're going to help people find
things on the web and they launched a
service called Yahoo which later became
a company and Yahoo was mostly in the
beginning a list of links here's some
cool stuff you might wanna check this
out you might check that out as the web
grew explosively the list got long and
then they had to start having lists of
lists and lists of lists lists and then
they realized they had a serious
information management problem on their
hands and they went after it by creating
a classification scheme they even hired
an ontology that was on her business
card Yahoo staff on chief ontology right
and here's the Yahoo top level
categories that should look familiar to
you it is categories which roll up two
subcategories the static subcategories
roll up to sub sub categories and so on
right here we are in the entertainment
category of the yahoo directory and you
can see here classic subcategories and
so forth and there's there's these sets
of numbers here which tell you roughly
how many links roll up under each of
these categories except over here books
and literature don't get a number they
get a little axe sign instead doesn't
tell you how many links roll up into
books and literature and that's because
books and literature aren't really here
right you know if you mistakenly think
that books are entertaining Yahoo is
happy to correct you because what the @
sign means is they're over there right
right books and literature or elsewhere
this is you know Xbox kind of stuff
right so you click that link right and
you're taking over 20 I see arts
humanities literature that's where books
go they're not entertainment so now we
get numbers and subcategories except
booksellers you know I mean a little
commercial right this is really about
aesthetics over here commerce is
someplace else right so booksellers
aren't really here right and the
ontological rich go of this is this kind
of link is no different than this kind
of link right you could see what
happened here Yahoo faced with the
possibility of having to organize things
without analog constraints added the
Shelf back
right they didn't know how to organize
it any other way or they assume that
their users would require this form of
organization or both and they added the
Shelf back they added back the
constraints that said things really go
someplace else and it's okay to put
pointers from other places but we can't
treat the pointers from other places as
being the same as where things really go
then in 1998 Google came along two guys
out of Stanford who decided they were
going to start a company to help people
find things on the web and Google
dispense with all of this and this is
Google's model instead there's a page
and it has a directed link to another
page except that when you blow that out
right you start to get a network and you
start to be able to look at the clusters
what goes with what what points to what
Google's principle intuition was that
the world wide web and even websites
were not real they're just metaphors
their ways we think about things all
that's real is the link structure and if
we analyze the link structure we can
pull a lot of value out that you can't
get from classification systems we all
remember what happened after Google
launched the interesting coded to this
story is that google also got worried I
said well yahoo has a directory they
have searched but they also have a
directory maybe we should get a
directory so then they got dmoz the open
source directory left that had come from
the Mozilla project now open source is
as everyone knows magic pixie dust and
it makes everything that you sprinkle it
on turn good all right so here we have
an open source version of the
categorization scheme a radically
different mode of production right and
once you see when you look through demoz
is exactly the same classes of errors
for instance if you go into recreation
or sports right rather looking
recreation sports if you're looking for
football it will tell you that football
is not recreation it's a sport it will
happily repoint you so you'll be correct
in the future but if you think that
football is recreation you're wrong all
so if you think that the football is
business you are wrong in other words
the class of errors made here had
nothing to do with the mode of
production now as I said earlier in the
talking about preservation in general we
don't have we don't yet know how large a
class of problem this is going to be
because we've had digital data around so
infrequently but we can infer some
things from the past and this time I
mean the deep past not the shallow past
we can ask have we lost anything in ways
analogous to the danger of
classification to the the brittleness
created by classification systems so
here's the Venus of Willendorf right
famous figurine discovered near
willendorf Germany she is a Paleolithic
fertility symbol we are told what is
that what is a fertility symbol right is
this a magical talisman to make women
bear children is it porn we don't know
right we don't have fertility symbols in
any in any form in our culture in a way
that makes it possible to read this
right we've lost the context we've kept
the object we've lost the context at
least however the object here is
informative there's a kind of visual
onomatopoeias or you can look at this
figurine and read a lot from and even
though you've lost the social context
the risk is that the more semantic
things get the bigger the context
problem so here are some things that
we've really lost top left is wrong go
wrong go it's the language from Easter
Island it may in fact there was some
debate as to whether or not this is a
language or merely a collection of
symbols which was evocative but not
communicative in the way we expect
language to be communicated in the
middle as quipu the the inca calculating
and recording system and at the bottom
is linear a a Mycenaean a Mycenaean
alphabet which actually seems to be
syllable based rather than
rather than letter based we can't read
any of these well there's enormous
effort going on they've all now been
partially decoded but we can't read any
of them well because unlike the Venus of
Willendorf there's nothing here if you
lose the semantics of a language you
lose everything right so this is much
more analogous to the digital
preservation problem than the Venus of
Willendorf because although these are
physical objects and we have the
physical objects having lost the having
lost the social context in which these
language or numbering systems existed we
have not been able to retreat here's
another thing this is something we
almost lost as hieroglyphs right the
official the official language of
dynastic Egypt and this disappeared as a
real written language and indeed as
anything anyone could read or write
sometime after the birth of Christ and
stayed unreadable for centuries and
would have continued to be unreadable
for at least some time but for this the
Rosetta Stone right this saved us is
kept hieroglyphs from falling into the
wrong go wrong go linear a category
because what went on here is that the
top part of the rosetta stone is
hieroglyphic the middle part is demotic
which is the vulgar Egyptian script
vulgar in the in the sense of of the
people script of Egypt that had come
from hieroglyphs in the bottom is Greek
right and when they saw the stone they
realized it must be the same thing
written out three different ways in
three different systems from three
different societies and working back
from that over the course of two decades
champion was able to finally decode
hieroglyphs and they went from lost to
found so what's the difference what's
the difference between what happened
with the Rosetta Stone and what happened
with rongorongo quipu and linear a and
the difference is degeneracy right now
probably a big waste of somebody's money
to fly in New Yorker out to the bay to
extol the virtues of degeneracy but in
the
case I have a particular meaning in mind
right degeneracy is the property of
systems where there's more than one way
to do things right so here we have three
simultaneous ways of encoding the same
meeting side by side had we in some
alternate history lost Greek but kept
demotic the rosetta stone would have
worked in the same way right so this is
not merely backup it's not merely
physical backup it is in a way
contextual backup right Christopher
Alexander makes this point Chris of
alexander's the architect who who
invented the idea of pattern languages
Christopher our calendar made this point
in an essay called a city is not a tree
by which he does not mean a tree with
green leaves but rather it is not a
hierarchical lattice and he says the
problem with planned cities is everyone
gets so excited about the planning they
forget about the city let's have all the
business in one place right and they'll
have the residential area in another
place then we'll have the transportation
hub over here all right and that's the
model on this side this is essentially a
Venn diagram version of what a hierarchy
looks like right and Alexander says real
cities are degenerate real cities have
multiple overlapping systems people live
where they work and the parks are
sometimes near the transportation hubs
and sometimes far away but there are
lots of overlaps right this is much
closer to what happened to the Rosetta
this is this is essentially what how the
Rosetta Stone saved saved us with
hieroglyph right so when you take this
representation of a hierarchy and you
take it back to the idea of a
classification system say we have two
big buckets right there's books about
art there's books about engineering some
of the art books are about creativity
and then somebody goes and publishes a
book about creativity and engineering
rot rot right now we've got a problem
because if i want to say there is a
literature of creativity in my library
I've lost the ability to give anybody a
top-level handle in the classification
system and this is also not a way to do
it because there are plainly things that
are in art and in engineering that are
not about creativity so I can't just
trivially reverse it the problem here is
in the require
for non overlap it's not in what the
overlaps are what's wrong what what
Alexander is talking about with planned
and unplanned cities and degeneracy is
the same issue that appears in
classification systems which is the
brittleness created by these kinds of
expectations creates a problem now I
don't mean to suggest that
classification systems the only way to
find things and libraries they have lots
of other systems many of them involving
free text search or other kinds of non
non classifying labels but back to the
point about economics the question
you're asking here is not are there ways
to find things but is the money spent on
building and maintaining these systems
worth the value right because everything
if preservation decisions are made on
the margin right then there may come a
day with a preservation system whether
where the individual systems are the
only thing the rosetta stone like strand
that holds the past to the future right
and since we know the awful math of time
is unlikely times many equals probable
right there may come a point at which
either the money spent on the the
expense taken by these systems coupled
with their brittleness actually leads to
some damage an obvious question that can
come out of this is what would a
degenerate labeling system look if you
didn't have to do it that way if you
didn't have to do it hierarchically if
you didn't have to support yourself
against overlaps what would you do
instead I think what you do would look
something like this and I don't mean
literally that it would look like a
rollerskating mermaid I mean the
rollerskating mermaid I think will help
illustrate the point first saturday of
every summer Coney Island are famously
rundown amusement park in Brooklyn plays
host to the Mermaid Parade hundreds of
people show up in costume they march
around thousands of people show up to
watch people get all dressed up there's
dancing in the streets as colorful
characters and a good time is had by
and the question is where did I get
those photos and the answers I got them
off a flicker of course I didn't take
those photos i went to flickr and i
found the tag Mermaid Parade so this
looks a lot like a classification scheme
like your looks like a library this
looks like a classification scheme there
is this thing called Mermaid Parade I
can go to it I can get these photos
right what's the advantage here over
what a libraries do one of the
advantages one of the difference is at
least is that flickr does not have a
staff on tala just it does not have
anybody doing the classified fact one of
the big differences here is the number
of people doing the class in this case
there are several thousand photos
there's over a hundred photographers and
every one of these photographers was not
just a photographer but also a kind of
librarian because they all added the tag
Mermaid Parade right so this is now not
a small group of professionals modeling
the group-mind on behalf of the larger
group right we think that they will
think about the concepts this way we
think that history is mainly broken down
by geography this is this is modeling
the group mind with the group mind the
second big difference here is that there
is no top level classification system
that's being adhered to right there's no
coordination among these 118
photographers it would in fact be too
expensive to do that coordination so
this is a distributed system which is
also low cost because the the people
doing the tagging are not being required
to coordinate with one of it in
something analogous to Google's model
flickers model is this right there are
more primitive than in Google's model
but they've added a tag which is
essentially a labeled link a tag and go
to a photo and tags come from users and
as with Google the real value here is
when you blow it out right you can start
to do network analysis but now you can
do network analysis on more primitives
right you can start looking not just at
link density but a tag density at user
density and so on you may have seen on
the Mermaid Parade page right that there
was this
related Coney Island in Brooklyn now
flickr doesn't know that the Mermaid
Parade is an event that happens in Coney
Island which is in Brooklyn right from
flickers point of view this is fubar and
fragments right these are just two tags
that appear at higher than average
frequency whenever they appear with the
tag Mermaid Parade and yet by doing the
cluster analysis flickers able to pull
this kind of value out here's another
example another system that uses tagging
this is delicious this is the headwaters
of the Nile Joshua schachter in fact the
inventor of delicious was the person who
invented the the word tagging to
describe this method of attaching labels
to thing as a side note it's interesting
to imagine that if he called them
categories or keywords a lot of this
would have would have been washed away
in the user assumptions but by calling
them tags which is right on that edge of
descriptive and strange he called a lot
of people's attention to the phenomenon
so delicious is a social bookmarks
manager it's analogous to backflip back
in the day where the day was nineteen
ninety-six or something except that had
it's got him it's got a more open and
social model so you add you add a link
here you get you get both the link and
and the title or whatever you type in
there you can add a descriptive line
your username is there and then you can
add these tags which are the labels just
like they just like they appeared on on
flickr and this is my favorite this is
my favorite from the moment i took this
snapshot cats in sinks it's a website
for pictures of cats in sinks or other
basin like objects right this this is
pretty much what the Internet has been
straining to become I think we can
probably all go home now the model here
is almost exactly the model of Flickr no
accident Joshua was the one who
convinced liquor to start using tags
except that instead of photos there's a
much more general purpose entity which
is being decorated by the tags anything
that has a URL can also be tagged and
you could begin doing the network
analysis there right so this enables us
to do things like
asking questions about how a given
resource has been characterized by the
community here is the delicious page for
one single URL it's about the linksys
router which is a very popular Wi-Fi
router made by the linksys unit of cisco
and how they've changed the underlying
linux operating system to a different
operating system but they haven't
changed the model number it's a geek
soap opera of epic proportion and you
can you can ask yourself you can see
here that's been tagged by 431 people
and you can ask yourself essentially how
is this being characterized and here's
the answer right the most common tag is
wrt54g which is just the the model
number from linksys right but then you
have this little cluster of three tags
linux Wi-Fi linksys and they're roughly
even right there roughly even so this is
a judgment that there's no one obvious
thing that this is about that part of
the reason this is important is it
exists at the overlap of a lot of
different trends right so this is one
kind of signature you can find in the
communal judgment about these resources
here's one for making a paper airplane
you can see here that there's not that
shelf there's really a much gentler
slope right paper airplane fun how to
games all fall off in this kind of
steady slope and you can see here that
the top two or paper airplane and you
can see how you maybe type paper
airplane but because delicious assumes
tags are separated by spaces it says
I'll will just treat papers one tag and
airplane is another right but the
communities judgment is that paper is
this is slightly more about paper than
it is about airplane which feels about
right right so even in things that are
very close there's some some information
in the distinction this is another tag
signature this is for CSS Vista which is
a piece of software for web designers
here the communities view is decisive
this is about CSS right software web
design tools design everything else is
on a completely different kind of curve
right this is absolutely about CSS
everything else is half as important or
less in the minds of all of the people
who've tagged
so the problem with classification
systems that is the rigidity of its in
or it's out right and even with
multiples you don't get out of the inner
out problem right Yahoo because of
course they could have had an unlimited
number of those little @ sign links also
said you can only have three links no
more right and the three number was more
about minimizing the amount of human
effort at Yahoo and defending against
spammers than any judgment about the
applicability of more than one category
to a topic right here not only do you
get places where people say this is
really kind of about these three things
whereas this is clearly about this one
if you're looking for sort of head
oriented tagging right you also don't
get it in this in or out quality the
community can not only tell you what
things are about they can tell you how
much they're about them relative to
other things this is this is a kind of
value that's not reflected in
classifications there is no such thing
as information architecture separated
from the users information doesn't have
architecture any more than information
wants to be free no no offense during
those are like the World Wide Web like
websites all metaphors but they are
unfortunately metaphors that block us
from recognizing that the problem here
is modeling the group mind for the users
right so one of the one of the
complaints about tagging systems the
tagging systems exist in a flat
namespace right the idea is that yes
they have this kind of labeling value
and that's fine but they don't create
the characteristics which hierarchy for
all its problems does about which things
go with which things in a kind of
nesting relationship all right so here's
what a flat namespace looks like right
these are three notional user names I'm
too embarrassed to say these are
actually three user names I've used in
the past so we'll just say someone has
used these user names at various points
you can imagine these as being three
names on livejournal are three names in
an eye on the line or whatever this is
actually a flat namespace this is a
namespace where no two of these names
are connected to one another they're
just labels that exist within the same
and the idea here right is that tagging
has the same characteristics that for
all of a kind of art engineering
creativity thing right within
hierarchies at least you can make some
of those kinds of statements but with
tags all you get is this right you get
post-it notes and nothing else but
that's not true because tags are
attached to urls and once you pull the
urls up you can see what tags go with
them so you can in fact do this right
hierarchy is in fact a subset of tagging
all right the Christopher Alexander
example showing nested you could you can
model hierarchies and tag form by simply
nesting tags inside other tags so the
boundaries never overlap but you can
also overlap the batteries and you can
start to get this where you can choose
to have a top-level handle about
creativity but you can also have the
overlap of art and creativity or the
overlap of art creativity and
engineering and so on and we were in
fact seeing this in real tagging systems
right if you go and you look on
delicious you'll see tags for Python and
Perl which are too lightweight
programming language I shouldn't say
lightweight to scripting programming
languages and then there's the tag
programming what you see when you
actually start to graph the overlaps
those the delicious is telling you that
Python and Perl each appear with
programming but don't appear with each
other in other words it's starting to do
the grouping that if you demand to see
everything is simply a pair X goes with
y X doesn't go with y pairwise
comparisons in a tagging universe or
hard but once you move to networks right
once you say these nodes exist in a
relationship with one another and we're
going to begin examining the group you
start to get informative information out
like this and you can continue with
other programming languages like C and
Java and so forth here's another
interesting thing C and Java are
connected to the tag software but Perl
and Python not so there's a judgment in
this community that C and Java are
different kinds of programming languages
they're more about software right so
these are heavier weight languages
is effectively my interpretation these
are heavier weight languages and these
are lighter weight languages these are
scripting languages whereas these
require some sort of compiling right and
the communities judgment right is that
software characterizes these kinds of
languages but not those kinds of layers
so once you move to network analysis the
overlaps are actually proving more
informative than they would in
classification systems right and finally
to the subject of time right we don't
have tags are only slightly over two
years old and in any scale we've had
them only a few you know a few month
depending what you think of a scale but
sort of tens of millions of URLs tagged
in any given system this is Pietro
peyronie's work he's he's in Italy and
he's doing a lot of work on what are
called tag cloud just essentially ranked
versions of tags and so he took a URL
here and he watched what happened to the
relative tag frequency and you could see
here right at the beginning when the
tags come out it's exactly as people
would expect of a distributed and
uncoordinated social system which is
basically chaos things are moving up and
down all the time but then right a week
and a half out or so suddenly not only
are the tags relatively stable but their
order relative to one another is
remarkably stable so like a market
setting a price for something this is a
way of taking a lot of individual work
which would be low value on its own and
rolling up into something that's
relatively high value and stable but
it's not always like this this is a
particularly flat one in some cases
right when a sub community gets hold of
these things right you can see the
relative tag frequencies change right
this is a URL which the information
architecture community discover it was
listed on a widely read information
architecture citing you can see these
tags when the frequency of some but not
all of the tags change that's
identifying the work of a community of
practice right and in fact you could
potentially isolate that group and say I
just want their judgment I don't in fact
once the whole thing and in some cases
although not many because as I said tags
are relatively young you can even see
the frequency shift
this is the tag cloud for Jesse James
Garrett's article about a design style
called Ajax asynchronous JavaScript +
XML it's essentially a way to make
browser interface is more responsive
right and you can see the red the red
line is the tag Ajax and you can see
when the article came out right that for
a couple of weeks Ajax was first of all
not much representative and then climb
quickly and in the beginning people said
this is an article about JavaScript it's
about XML it's about browsers and he's
proposing the label Ajax and you can see
as the article circulates that the
proposed label takes hold right and at
some point the community says this is an
article about Ajax which is these other
things this is the picture of a
community changing its mind right we can
actually see right this is the antidote
to the former Soviet Union problem which
is things change as they change when you
start modeling the group mind with the
group mind the dynamic signature tells
you when things are being all so here
are let me end with a set of questions
that I'm asking myself about this
because this is all this is all quite
new and in particular tags have not been
tested at long time frames so while it
seems to offer the answer in the digital
realm to some of the brittleness of
classification systems there are still
lots of open issues first of all the one
I alluded to in the in the little social
quake diagram how can tagging identify
communities of practice right can we
find ways of observing groups that come
together and exhibit similar tag
frequencies can we pull that out of the
mix and say these people seem more
design oriented whereas those people
seem more engineering oriented and then
is there value in reflecting back to
those communities their view of the of
the resource being tagged as opposed to
having them look at the view of the
community as a whole right how should we
handle the thesaurus problem that the
source problem is I tagged something
menu you take it menus I tagged at
restaurant you take it restaurants
plainly there would be some value in
rolling those things together so they're
basically the same so you make it
thesaurus you say well agenda and
politic and politics we're going to roll
together or you say we're going to roll
together Apple and mac and OS X we're
going to roll together a gay and queer
and homosexual right and then suddenly
you're saying that queer politics and
homosexual agenda are the same thing
right you don't want to get the queer
politics and homosexual agenda people in
the same room to talk about their shared
interests right so at some point you
have to get off the thesaurus bus the
irony of the thesaurus is if you move to
a system like this and then start the
thesaurus thesaurus izing whatever that
word would be at the center you're
recreating the problems of having a
small group of cataloguers manage the
system for you so applying a thesaurus
to these things clearly means to be
happen late in the system and it needs
to be done on the client side on the
other hand it's a high-cost operation so
is there a way to syndicate a thesaurus
to groups so that i could subscribe to
the information architecture thesaurus
but it would be applied to the tags
after i was looking at them rather than
having things smashed at the server
right can we apply this to navigation
one of the places where classification
systems are still in in common use in
the digital realm is when you get the
width versus depth trade-off enforced by
screen real estate you go to the
homepage of GE they've got their
businesses broken down into three top
level categories and then drop boxes for
the subcategories and so forth it is it
is a classic classification scheme is
there a way to model the group mind with
the group mind that applies to
navigation not just to the sort of
search and finding paradigm right so
can't and and one answer to this is that
there is no expert amateur split here
experts can also tag can you set up a
navigation system where experts people
inside do all the tagging for navigation
system so the navigation system is is
set up but that users can come in and
slowly correct them if they're wrong
right I was a hunter college and we were
redesigning the homepage
in 1998 I think and the Registrar
refused to believe that students didn't
know what the Registrar did so he
insisted that there be a button on the
home page that said registrar and we
said well you know students don't know
that that means where's the course
schedules where's the class descriptions
where are my grades that's just a word
that no no no absolutely not the
Registrar wanted registrar on the
homepage right so that's a place where
the inside judgment was actually adverse
relative to the community is there a way
that we can embed community correction
into navigation so the site can know not
just the users what we can discover from
these systems popularity risk I should
actually let Dana give this part of the
talk the popularity risk is the idea
that although we're getting these
refined social signatures of what
something is about right the lazy way
out is just give me the top five tags
I'll just I'll just take the community's
judgment about this job I don't care
about micro subcultures tagging things
weigh it out on the tail just show me
what everybody agrees right and that
potentially creates popularity risk
which is to say that the overall social
judgment of something becomes so
overwhelming that acquires some of the
same brittleness as cataloguing systems
and that novel opinions about a resource
or subculture opinions about a resource
never get aired it's an open question I
mean so many of these things are open
questions because these sorts of systems
are so young can we detect concept rock
I was at the digital library foundation
Federation meeting a couple of weeks ago
and we were talking about large-scale
systems and how past a certain scale you
sort of move to biological models and
someone said you know what's great about
biological systems when they go bad they
start to stink and you can tell right we
saw Ajax going up right can we detect
when fertility symbol starts to go down
right can we actually look at this not
just for bit rot but for concept right
so that some of the concepts were using
to hold our ideas together are starting
to go away and we can at least take
steps right to replace alter them find
other ways of expressing the same
thoughts and so and finally of course
what can we do about
spam right spam which has been regarded
there's a kind of surface level
annoyance is in my view a pretty deep
problem because open social systems
create a lot of value and the incentive
to mine that value has nothing to do
with the incentive to contribute to that
value right the more open these systems
become the more valuable they will
become the bigger the target they will
become and ten years ago when global
alert for allah jesus is coming soon or
the green card spammers came on Usenet
we could be forgiven for not
understanding the nature of the threat
but now we know exactly the nature of
the threat and we're going to face a
well-defended and motivated enemy is
there something we can do to continue to
increase the value of these kinds of
systems without falling prey to spam and
with that all in
I saw online that you said one time that
the only group that can categorize
everything is everybody is that what
you've just said that's that's
effectively what I've just said what I
would say now which is maybe a little
more nuanced is I wasn't I wasn't as
focused on the idea of communities of
practice because we hadn't yet seen them
appearing so I think that the definition
of everybody's not necessarily the
global culture but everybody you you
care about everybody who everybody who's
part of the group you're part of and so
sometimes you may want the global view
right now what is the best Chinese
restaurant Chinatown and sometimes you
may want the view of your specific
community but I do think that's
indicating i do think that's indicating
the labeling problem is similar to
syndicating the pricing problem in
markets well of the same sort of scale
category with everything and everybody
is all time where does that fit into
this it fits in well it fits in in a lot
of places and we don't know so well
because of the because of the short
timeframe that that these things have
already been done but one of the one of
the interesting longer-term projects is
how stable do these label groups remain
over time the potential advantages that
if they remain relatively stable then we
can watch for two kinds of changes we
can watch for changes where tag
frequency adjusts either those little
social quakes which are potentially
identifying a new community of practice
or where a tag begins to go out of scope
or come up is with Ajax but the other
thing we can watch for is when people
stop tagging because these things are
continually being retag many of them are
decades all they've been things that
have been on the web for for more than
10 years but a new user just found them
interesting and that that is part of the
continually refreshed possibility for
action right when a particular URL stops
getting paid attention to at all we can
also say that's at risk we would love to
be able to know that things are at risk
before the risk happens which is what
which is the opportunity we missed with
the BBC micro in the Doomsday project
how about is this changes of technology
come on not only things sort of rotting
away but in a sense technology quakes
like social quake so for example we get
to the point where the Internet has way
more devices on it than there are people
does that affect this kind of thing yeah
it does and and and one of the questions
is can can can you bootstrap from this
kind of semantics to have devices start
doing doing the characterizing and
that's that's really an AI problem
that's that's out of the scope of the
current research they say but certainly
the two things you'd like to be able to
do is say either this resource is coming
from these kinds of sensors of these
kinds of devices it's similar to X and
the absence of any human intervention
we're going to adopt this set of tags
for it to make it find a ball and then
what you'd really like to be able to do
is take advantage of latent semantic
analysis or other these kinds of tools
to have the machines make additional
kinds of guesses I think in some cases
you'll have to have a balance between
the guess is being made by the machines
and corrected by the humans so there may
be a kind of waiting algorithm this has
only been characterized by the machines
has been characterized by lots of
machines and a few humans and so on but
it's you know and that's a distinction
will care about for a while but not
right exactly yes exactly mostly
original substrate humans as joe says al
links are a peculiar thing in all this
because links structures age quickly
dead links accumulate and do they
undermine this whole system they don't
because when they go out of scope well
first of all the system I think if it
proves valuable and over the long term
it can actually help us find when a link
is broken because if something's being
tagged some relative frequency and that
suddenly stops we can go and look for it
right because there are many places
where it's going to be cached for 30 or
90 days or what have you have and then
we can potentially go back to snapshots
and so forth so once something goes away
we can pretend to go back to whether
it's the google cache or internet
archive Andrey replicated elsewhere for
a while for a while but you know DNA
only lasts
for a while turns out that little bits
of for a while as long as they overlap
this way is that it this way can be
relatively can be relatively useful so
the idea that biological systems stink
in a way if you can find immediately
that there's a problem because the
stream of bookmarking to a link stops or
attenuates or radically changes right
you can potentially call it either some
automated or human intervention the
other thing is you start to get you
start to be able to say if you pull in
the content with the Tagus is not
something delicious does but you can
plainly write your own spider I'm
someone who cares about preserving
content that travels under a particular
tag this enormously lowers the
difficulty of doing it right the
distributed hard disk use of RSS feeds
is this incredible latent resource that
we haven't yet taken advantage of for
syndicating but we may be able to build
preservation tools on top of that as
well just to track on your metaphor for
one minute there the somatic DNA goes
away body DNA but germline DNA is
basically a journal right but is there
the equivalent of that in the system
germline DNA is eternal becoming
germline DNA is classically the Refresh
possibility for action which is to say
continually recreated the information
content is continually recreated in
different physical substrates so this
this is not a preservation system but I
believe it has ramifications for
preservation systems by allowing for
exactly that sort of refreshed refresh
possibility I'll ask one more question
in mind sorry about this but you were
part of a online discussion i was in
recently he was talking about long tail
and how lots and lots of participants
there's the usual 80 20 and 20 people
doing eighty percent of the comments or
whatever it might be and so on down to
the other direction and you remark that
you thought the this is the popularity
question you couldn't actually take away
the long tail even though it's
relatively unimportant part of the whole
picture you say it is an important part
of the whole picture and you can't just
go with the top five
and get meaning what's going on there
what's that that argument hello that
argument is that way that this part of
the graph looks not important in terms
of the total number of tags being added
because it's not the social wait isn't
behind this but it is part of what makes
the ecosystem work so that what you've
really got here is the replacement for a
professional system which is going to
optimize around these kind of relatively
narrow constraints to being able to have
stuff all the way out to the singletons
all the tags that one and only one
person is used and then it's as an
ecosystem the tagging is succeeding if
you try to limit the ecosystems and say
we're actually just going to truncate
all the tagging here I think you have
you have something that was less
effective and less successful the other
thing that's weirding me out about these
graphs is that the test that probably
what do you mean you could tell I don't
know you you know one of the things you
already exactly just just take a tagging
system and truncate it but one of the
other things it's weirding me out about
these grasses there's often an internal
shelf after the most popular there's to
hear these little internal shells and I
can't tell if they're noise or if that
really is some bump in the the gree
social cohesion among among the users
but I think that may also be some sign
of some some value from the tail is
being able to detect when something has
walked off the edge of it's sort of
broadly adopted of the broadly adopted
semantic judgment community and then
you're getting that and I don't think
you can get that kind of value without
having the full range of participation
okay a couple of kind of bug fixing
questions about tags one from alexander
rose who is we're waiting back there and
another from luis rosado here alexandra
asks how does i'll ask you both how does
tagging deal with heavily faction
definitions like abortion right Louis s
what about the problem of people gaming
tags trying to crawl cause an outcome
analogous to sperm by the way analogous
with span
try and get in what are you there well
44 anyway gaming goes on right right I
I'll put those two together the
contentious subjects just get I mean if
you if you had say the equivalent of a
Wikipedia edit war on the on the
pro-life pro-choice thing because
tagging is very much in the wisdom of
crowds mode of great disassociation
among people tagging you would simply
get in rank order what tags people were
using there may well be coordination
behind the scenes in those camps I don't
know that we've seen that yet but the
overall surface change would simply be
to bump up the relative frequencies of
certain tags that's a place that
intersects with popularity risk it's a
little bit San alaga to Google bombing
right where some small group of highly
collected bloggers is able to change a
relatively obscure phrase on Google and
then circulate it right if someone
started adopting the top five tags model
for any given tagging system to
characterize a resource then someone who
wanted to go in a determined pro-life or
pro-choice camp could potentially just
below the tag count through the roof for
their their characterizations and deny
other groups the ability to see their
characterizations reflected that's a
speculative class of attack but there's
certainly no defense in the system
against it right now if people begin
adopting the kind of top five tags or
popular tags mantra in terms of people
trying to game the system that's
happening now there are there are people
who are already doing the most obvious
forms of spamming just going in with it
with a URL and tagging it everything so
it shows up in every possible every
possible tag string the delicious way of
handling that is never to show more than
12 tags from one user on their homepage
no matter how many tags are underneath
and the the co on posed by Joshua is if
the if it doesn't look like spam to the
user is it spam so rather than trying to
remove the
things in the system he's simply trying
to make it look like the kind of
constant background flow back in the day
delicious would show you I think the top
couple of hours of tags now it's showing
you at most two or three minutes of tags
the I showed both the yahoo directory
and the dmoz directory which is the
largest attempts to categorize the web
classify the web in sort of standard
hierarchical form each of those has
roughly four-and-a-half million unique
URLs in it delicious has more than
double that number and is growing at the
rate of twenty twenty unique URLs a
minute or so so in a way the kind of
public attention of spam is heavily
attenuated by this by the flow through
the system the real risk the spam
becomes people watching obscure feeds if
I have if I'm watching something called
s bestest right if I'm watching a tag
called asbestos then people shoving
things done to that may be able to get
my attention but it is it is right now a
predator-prey problem with with spammers
my guess is in this system and in a lot
of systems we're going to move to a kind
of grey list world where not just white
list it's not just show me the tags of
all of my friends but show me all of
their friends tags and wait those
friends somehow at roughly fifty percent
and may be friends of friends at
twenty-five percent so that I have this
kind of semi permeable membrane instead
of having a white list and a castle I
have this gradient of potentially
socially valuable information coming
from unknown sources into the system but
these are all again because tagging is
so young these are all speculative class
of a tax inspected of class of defense
but but I do think that a lot of that
experimentation is coming well you
mentioned the Wikipedia I'm curious how
many here use Wikipedia
there was a great sort of whooshing
sound as all the hands win in the air
William Petrie who is where right over
here asked how do you feel about things
that fall between your two poles like
Wikipedia categories right right so
Wikipedia categories are interesting
they have the same problems as these
kind of categories they have the same
problems as other categorization systems
and I'm sorry I didn't see where you I
they have the same problems as other as
other categorization systems in that
hierarchy imposes a dilemma right the
lattice structure and poses a dilemma on
the user's the really interesting thing
about the Wikipedia to me is that almost
no the category systems that almost no
one uses it right if you if you google
in URL for the category colon tag in
Wikipedia you get almost nothing right
so like like Google removing dommage
from the homepage in fact I don't think
I told that part of the story but when
Google put dmoz up on the homepage right
and they had the entire world's
attention for for finding things for a
period have no one went to Deemas so
then they took it back off the homepage
and when I was talking about some of
these issues a few months ago somebody
from yahoo came up after the talk and
said you know it was funny to hear you
talking about that when we were at Yahoo
talking about the redesign of the
homepage the only debate was should we
move the yahoo directory all the way to
the bottom of the page or should we just
get rid of it entirely and we basically
kept it right but you know greatly
de-emphasized its its importance so the
category system on Wikipedia is not
getting a lot of attention because it
turns out not to be the principal tool
for finding one of the one of the really
important things to understand about
tagging is people are often weighing
tagging systems against classification
systems as if and of course I'm just
giving a whole talk that emphasizes
exactly that tagging systems
classification systems as if they exist
in the same world one of the key things
to understand about tagging systems is
they are post search right this is the
first post search finding technology it
assumes that search is a mature and
widely adopted technology so where's
classification had to fit a bunch of
different cat
stories of looking for things tagging
can be much more narrowly focused
because search solves that problem I
think the same thing is happening to the
Wikipedia which is wikipedia has a
largely search oriented either you know
the word or Google knows the word and
the categorization system although it
has the same brittleness the brittleness
isn't a problem because Wikipedia is
highly degenerate here's a Kevin Kelly
question sitting right here I says
associative clustering like tags is how
biological memory works right is the web
now thinking no no I had to go get my
point yeah the bread my the problem I
have with all of those questions is I
don't know that we know how we're
thinking yet I mean that the and and
since it's not my area all I can do is
pair at the most recent book I've read
on the subject which is the Adelman on
on the idea that that neural networks
are actually evolutionarily adaptive I
think what's being evolutionarily
adapted here is more in the manner of a
tool than a brain so that you can see
for instance someone did a great study
on the the adaptive characteristics of
French horns right in the collection of
French horns as if they were snails and
you could see the forms change over time
as musicians started to ask for minor
modifications and there's propagated so
my guess is that link structure is being
adapted by humans more in the man or the
tool rather than becoming autopoietic
but that's that's I'm a layperson on all
of those issues so that's that's that's
just a guess well it's interesting to me
here is what you've been talking about
tonight in terms of tags being of the
essence is a pretty recent emergent
phenomenon on the net you studied you
know the ancient era back to the well
and things like that was there anything
going on then that would have led
somebody like yourself to say that
tagging is going to be important no and
interestingly and and this could have
just been because I
missed it the we were getting a lot of
evidence that the other thing was that
hierarchical and brittle systems were
not working well in fact the first the
first thing I saw online which really
suggested that the brittleness of
classification systems was going to be a
problem was usenet where they overlap
two different requirements one globally
unique names of conversations and to the
semantic content of those conversations
so you got wrecked pets cats where you
know everybody in the whole world who
likes cats is going to come and hang out
right and the the brokenness of that
system essentially meant anybody who
wants to talk about anything even
remotely related to feminism goes to
this one place and it was of course a
permanent standing flame war until he
went moderated right social culture
african-american which never got
moderate it was just a permanent
standing flame war and that was a case
where the brittleness of the
classification system of trying to make
the the low-level machine requirements
of names based map to semantic content
was a disaster I think if I could have
predicted what the response would be I'd
have been smarter than I am I'd have
been Joshua instead of me I guess what
I'm in noticing is it since tags was
noticed so recently and it's so
fundamental there's probably more of
those yet um right and I should I should
say too I don't I mean I think
degenerate yeah i think the degeneracy
of the system and the syndication of
modeling the group mind with the group
mind is what's fundamental there's lots
of issues with our current tagging
systems for instance they're not
trivially exchangeable between systems
because systems system context matters
so much so I can't say that the systems
we're looking at now are going to be the
things that last forever but I do
believe that that degenerate labeling
and syndication is going to last a long
time here's question a couple of on sort
of preservation of information in
general Adrian Kotter is it over here do
we want to make all information durable
isn't there things we might want to
forget and be happy to let go of such as
your
flames yes the yeah there's there's
there's I think what we want is is
control Stewart do you want a global
delete that you control I know so I was
going to say isn't gonna bring up the
yo-yo story actually Stewart stirred the
pot on this 20 some odd years ago with
the phrase you own your own words on on
the well which was meant to be a
statement of I think personal
responsibility but turned into a global
retroactively copyright and control
issue and is still phenomenally
phenomenally complicated and there's a
lot of conversation right now about the
idea that you own your own data you own
your data which of course you manifestly
don't it's observable everywhere right
when i go to have a conversation with
you you and I were both in that
conversation and i can't take what i
said back in some systems whether it was
one and only one copy you could in fact
go take it back as on caucus you can't
do that on using that as i have
discovered to my horror so yeah there's
certainly stuff out there that i would
be happy not to have but i think the
issue is i don't i don't think we want
to trivially record everything for all
time simply because the forgetting is an
important part of being human and there
are things you want to be able to forget
or remove or delete what I think we
don't want to do is I think we don't
want to accidentally lose things and I
think we especially don't want to
accidentally lose them in this sort of I
thought you had the car keys way right
we're within the BBC right well we put
this on laserdisc we had these computers
and then the computers didn't work out
and we got rid of everybody and all of a
sudden right and it really took them
four or five years even to figure out
that they couldn't get back to the
material so i think what i'm talking
about here is is what these systems
point2 i think is all steps 2 through n
where once something is out there right
we'd like to be able to watch it would
like to be able to characterize it we'd
like to be able to have lots of sort of
degenerate views of it but whether or
not it's out there is up is that
to the user now one of the things that's
always been true about large-scale
systems is it's very hard to retract
things and people who were used to
office email don't understand why the
whole internet can't have one of those
I'd like to take that email back buttons
but those don't it's much harder to
model that in an end-to-end network than
it is in a controlled Network so the
personal risk for losing content you'd
rather have rather have controlled once
it's out there it's almost impossible to
delete but I think the question of
whether or not we we omit that data is
separate from one submitted how do we
how do we characterize and handling it's
interesting just to tell a story from
the well back in 84 85 86 because it was
relatively open software on their Pecos
ban and everybody was messing around in
the UNIX inside it some of the users
invented commands like delete everything
I ever wrote on the system